at 19 I was raped in the army and
sexually harassed on a daily basis a
female sergeant told me not to tell I
didn't to this day I rarely admit I'm a
soldier to avoid questions I was
sexually assaulted in the military
diagnosed with PTSD and now I have to
explain to my dad why I failed him and
the army is chapter in me out I have a
horrible suspicion that the rest of the
country thinks the military has curbed
sexual assault we have it
we just don't tell anymore I did and it
ruined my career
I served in the Army for six years when
I went to Iraq I was shot at raped and
went through a divorce freedom isn't
free it comes at a high price
PTSD I reported it I saw him every day
for two months at the article 32 hearing
I was told that my character was in
question and I wasn't drunk enough he
got promoted and away with it I have two
sexual assault cases to go through they
both happened overseas I hate wearing
this uniform I just don't feel
comfortable in the military anymore I am
a female Marine I was raped last week
when I was passed out drunk another
statistic
I got sexually assaulted by my superior
second time in the military what's wrong
with me I have combat PTSD and military
sexual trauma I feel like I'm batshit
crazy I was sexually assaulted on
deployment and nothing was done about it
it hurts me every day that the world's
greatest Navy still denies what happened
to me I was drugged and gang-raped by
fellow soldiers the nightmares and
anxiety are slowly killing me a lot of
times I miss being in the Army but then
I remember why I chose to get out being
sexually assaulted by a sergeant
completely ruined any thought of wanting
to serve any longer